handheld is gonna just be an accessory
and it's going to be 150 and then you
bundle you bundle that with the
PlayStation 5 for 650 maybe throw in
Spider-Man 2 for 700. with a Spider-Man
song and you give it in the Box song if
they're a most expensive accessory now
apart from the psvr 2 headset is that
whatever that that dual sense Edge
controller at almost 200 if you could
hit that price point or is it almost 200
it's just it is 200 actually yeah
so if you could hit that price point or
below
100 I can see the liability so so check
it out all right so I'm tired of hearing
y'all yeah and then we got an entire
finish but yeah and it's funny
all right it's just a firsthand help no
not not at all right no no right did
they do all those stuff that y'all said
they was going to do the last time with
the last handheld